[Music]
is
a
[Music]
well hey you guys yeah it's Saturday and
I'm doing another solo live stream and
finally I'm getting around to doing
another TOS of Terror another book
review cuz I haven't done one for such a
long time cuz I really haven't had much
time to read in the last few weeks which
really sucks um like I said I'm still
working on Braum's slooh foot which I
would really like to finish at some
point I think I'm only about a quarter
the way through it and at this point I
haven't read it for so long that I might
have to like start it over cuz I don't
like remember what happened so what I
decided to do was I was kind of going to
go on my Kindle unlimited thing and look
for some stuff that was shorter that I
could just read in you know a couple of
hours uh so I would at least have a book
to talk about cuz I know that some of
you guys really like the book reviews
even more than the movie reviews but you
know like I said I don't get as much
time to read as I used to so this time
around I'm talking about now they're
calling it a short story although I
guess I would term it more a Nolla I
guess it's 58 Pages at least the ebook
version I don't even think there's a
print version to be honest um and I
didn't okay so I didn't even know about
this I was just kind of scrolling
through Kindle unlimited looking for
something short that I could just read
in a couple of hours and this novela
came up and it's called the pram by Joe
Hill and I didn't realize when I first
checked it out that is actually part of
a series so apparently what Amazon did
like in like this year in the run-up to
Halloween like at the beginning of
October or something they're starting to
do this new thing and I kind of hope
that they do this every year now
but they they kind of put out like six
Standalone novellas by six different
kind of popular horror authors and
they're if you have Kindle unlimited
which I do you can read them for free
and I think at least I'm pretty sure
this is what happened like when I
downloaded the Kindle unlimited version
to my library it also automatically gave
me a free um audiobook version from
audible which I didn't listen to cuz I
just read it but um but I thought that
was pretty cool that they're just like
giving it away for free like if you have
a subscription and I'm assuming if you
have a subscription to audible then you
would get the ebook for free as well if
you don't have the Kindle unlimited
because those are two different things
but yeah so I got the audible thing for
free speaking of which before I get too
far into it um I am an uh audible
affiliate uh they're a sponsor of 13:00
so if you click there's a link down in
the description box and if you click on
this link then you actually get a$3 day
free trial of audible uh which obviously
is Amazon's uh you know audiobook
repository which also has lots of
podcasts and things like that thousands
thousands perhaps Millions uh of stuff
that you can listen to during this
30-day free trial you can listen to
anything you want on there for nothing
for no points and you also get um one
point to use like for something that you
can buy on there that you can keep
forever if you're are if you're already
like an Amazon Prime member then you
actually get two points to spend on you
know stuff that you can keep forever
also so it's a really good deal uh so
like I said my uh link is down in the
description box so if you click on that
link um I get a small commission but
also you get the 30-day trial and like I
said it's a really good deal audible is
a really cool service so you know please
think about clicking that link and
subscribing please and thank you so yeah
so it seems as though any one of these
six books which I've checked all of them
out cuz I'm eventually going to think
about probably reviewing them at some
stage but um you know if you do download
them to your Kindle library and it will
also give you like an audiobook version
which I thought was kind of cool so the
other five list this one was Joe Hill
and I so I'm going to read this one
first because this was the first one I
guess they're numbered it doesn't I
don't I don't know why they're numbered
but I don't know if they came out like I
don't know I don't know if they just
that was the first one that came out so
I well this is number one so I'm going
to read this one and I really like Jo so
you know what I mean but the other ones
uh there's one by Grady Hendrick which
I've actually already read which so I
might review that one uh a little while
to in a little while too there's one by
Josh malerman uh who wrote bird boox
among other things uh there's one by
Paul tremble there's one by Jason Mott
and there's one by Chandler Baker so and
they all look pretty good like they all
have kind of standardized covers and
they're all Amazon's calling it their
creature features collection so they're
all kind of monstery type stories which
is cool I really like that so they're
thematically similar but they're
completely different stories at least as
far as I could determine so yeah so I'm
kind of hoping that Amazon does this
every year for Halloween that would be
really really cool because you get to
read like all these stories by all these
authors for you know essentially free
even you know it having a kind unlimited
subscription isn't free but you know
what I mean so like I said I decided to
start with Joe Hill's story it's 58
pages long at least in the ebook version
uh and as I mentioned it's called the
pram now I've really liked all of Joe
Hill's works that I've read I haven't
read um Nas Fatu yet but I did read
horns and Heart-Shaped Box and like a
couple of the other ones and those two I
really really liked a lot and I thought
this story was really just as brilliant
as those now I will say that this
particular novela I dug the concept of
it so much that I almost almost wish
that it had been expanded into a full
length length
novel then again I mean on the other
hand um there is kind of something to be
said for just this very brief nasty
story um and and the fact that the lore
I mean if that's what you want to call
it is only kind of explained in really
short strokes and it leaves a lot to the
imagination um you know horror is I
think I've mentioned many many many many
times like on the show I think better
when it's left somewhat ambiguous now
that's not to say that this story like
leaves a bunch of questions unanswered
it doesn't really it does kind of like
fill in some lore around you know the
the sect at the center of this but it's
not overexplained and I think that
that's you know to the story's benefit
you know what I mean I thought it was
like a good length so this is the setup
of the story so you have a couple named
Willie and
MaryAnn and they prior to the events of
the story there they'd been living in
this kind of cramped uh condo in
Brooklyn I think it was so at some point
in the past year or something like that
Maryanne has a miscarriage and this was
a baby that both of them had very much
wanted so this was like a really
horrible like tragedy right now maranne
understandably after this happened like
falls into this really profound
depression um that she's in for like
months like she just lays around the
house in the dark and like doesn't clean
or doesn't go anywhere and doesn't do
any work and all this other kind of
stuff and she's just devastated you know
what I mean like I said understandably
and Willie her husband I mean for his
part he seemed to suffer the loss just
as deeply as she did but he didn't seem
to necessarily deal with it in a real
productive way because he was so focused
on worrying about his wife that he was
kind of
maybe not uh addressing his own grief or
his own mental illness which or you know
mental health I guess is what I meant to
say but it's just kind of like which I
think is kind of common in that sort of
situation uh for for men in that
situation they would just be like not
even realize that they are also mourning
the loss of a child or you know you know
a baby that they had wanted um because
they're so worried about their wife and
I think that that's kind of what is
happening here
um on top of that he also came down with
covid and lost his sense of smell which
does actually kind of play into the
story a little bit like as the time goes
on um so all of this information is kind
of conveyed in bits like through
flashbacks because like I said this kind
of happened like prior to the events of
the
story now at some stage during the
aftermath of the
miscarriage Willie becomes really
preoccupied with I need to get Maryanne
away from this condo like where the
tragedy took because it happened in the
condo you know what I mean the the
miscarriage and he's starting to think
of the place as like a morg like we'll
never be able to live here ever again
because like every time we go in that
bathroom or whatever we're just going to
see that so he decides he's going to get
her the [__] out of there and that's
going to help so he does all this
research and he eventually finds this
beautiful Farmhouse um for cheap which
is kind it's kind of run down but like
can be fixed up you know what I mean and
it's kind of in this
isolated town called hobom in Maine now
the weird thing about this that you find
out at the beginning as they're driving
out there with the realtor is that
Maryanne actually grew up in Maine um
only a few miles from where this town is
is located and she's never heard of it
which she thinks is very strange now the
realtor claims that this is just because
oh well this town is just so off the
beaten path but Maryann kind of makes an
off-hand comment while they're on the
way out there that she almost attributes
like sort of like a magical property
maybe like to this town like oh maybe
it's only there like for people who need
it or something like that so you can
tell that there's already some kind of
maybe Supernatural kind of [__] going on
right now when William Mary and see The
Farmhouse um they're just completely
both Charmed by it and MaryAnn seems to
like perk right up she's just like oh my
God this place is beautiful and she's
thinking of all the stuff she can do
with it and you know she really seems to
get her groove back I guess and the town
itself of hobom is like really really
Charming also in like this real super
19th century kind of way you know what I
mean um well in fact while they're out
and about or before they even get to The
Farmhouse they see this couple on the
they're walking on the side of the road
that they think are Amish like just the
way they're dressed and stuff like that
but you know they got like the frock
coats and the Bonnet with the big Bonnet
and everything like that but the realtor
tells them well this is a similar
religious sect to the Amish but slightly
different it's the town's people call
them the sin Planters okay it's and she
says well there's not a lot of them and
most of the ones that are left are like
really old you know they're like in
their 80s or 90s but they still like
contribute to the local economy by you
know selling their produce and they do
like hand churn butter and all that kind
of stuff like to the Country Store
that's there in town right so after
Willie and Maryanne kind of settle into
this new Rural Life that they're having
Willie finds that he enjoys they both
work at home so you know what I mean
that's that taken care of you know what
I mean um so he finds that he enjoys
walking to the Country Store now you can
get to it like through this kind of
circuitous route but there's kind of a
shortcut that goes through this path in
the woods and it has like all of these
trees over it like a tunnel and it's
really really and he thinks it's really
really beautiful and peaceful out there
and Willie eventually learns that the
ancestors of the current sin planter
people like the sect they planted all of
those trees out there like a long time
ago and also that they cut themselves to
like feed the trees with their blood
which sounds a little bit unsettling to
say the least but nobody seems to have
anything bad to say about this
implanters and it's just kind of like
hey they just keep to themselves and
that's kind of you know how it goes you
know now during one of Will's grocery
runs to the Country Store the nice old
man that runs the place who's like an
English dude named Brian he loans Willie
this real janky old classic pram like a
baby carriage you know what I mean to
carry his groceries back to his house in
because he bought so much stuff that was
heavy and he's like you know you don't
want to walk a mile back in the woods
like carrying all this [__] so he gives
her this he gives him this baby carriage
now over the course of the story and
like I said this is a pretty short story
it's only like 58
Pages Willie starts to believe I'm
trying not to give too much of it away
but he does start to believe that the
pram sometimes has a baby in it okay
okay and he starts getting obsessed with
this thing like to the point where it
seems like at times that he might be was
kind of losing his marbles a little bit
okay so there's that kind of whole
situation and like I said I don't really
want to spoil what happens like other
than that but that's kind of like the
only hint that I want to give you so as
I said I mean this was a great story I
really lik this a lot I mean Joe Hill
he's just a really good writer and he's
really fantastic at conveying just this
Eerie mood about this town and
particularly about this path through the
woods with just a few words you know
what I mean like I could really vividly
Picture This Town like the house and the
path and the store and everything and
the shed out back and all that kind of
stuff I could just really vividly
picture it in my mind and he was so he's
really good at like painting a picture
without over explaining things you know
what I mean um and Willie uh from who's
we're seeing everything from his
perspective it's not in first person
it's actually in limited third but we're
seeing like everything from his
perspective pretty much um he's just
he's a really relatable character I mean
he's clearly very bitter about the
miscarriage and about like all these
kind of terrible things that have
befallen him and his wife in the past
year however long it's been um but he
does seem to be trying to deal with it
usually through kind of like a black
sense of humor but as we see he's not
dealing with it maybe as well well as he
thought he was uh you know so that kind
of plays into it as well now I will say
that and I don't want to go too far in
this direction but the themes of the
pram are somewhat similar to the themes
of pet cemetery which of course was
written by Joe Hill's dad Stephen King
many years ago and I'm you know like I
said they're not similar similar stories
but the themes are it's thematically
kind of similar because it in the sense
that they're both written from the point
of view of a father who has lost a child
and is having a hard time coming to
terms with that you know what I mean and
and kind of like leads him down a dark
path eventually you know leads him down
a dark path um and interestingly too and
I think there was a little bit of this
in Pet Cemetery as well but I think it
was kind of more um it's it's kind of
more clear here I think but the
character of Willie in this seems at
first
to be like completely unaware that he's
also grieving the miscarriage and this
lack of awareness kind of causes him to
retreat into anger and resentment
towards his wife you know for like it
being her fault you know what I mean
even though he doesn't obviously think
that consciously but unconsciously he
maybe does blame her and but it seems
like he's not really fully cognizant of
that
and so that in turn kind of acts as the
Catalyst for this Supernatural angle
that comes along later and kind of plays
into the story as going it's almost kind
of like it's you know feeding on that
type of thing so I'm going to say like
I'm I'm sure that some people reading
this might um wish that like I said it
was longer that like the back more of
the backstory of the sin Planters was
fleshed out or you know Will's um
destructive emotion were kind of you
know explored further maybe but to be
honest I mean I thought this was pretty
much uh the perfect length I think it
got across the horror of the story in
just a really good like economic fashion
like it gave you just enough information
for you to get like invested in the
characters and invested in the situation
and then when [__] starts going sideways
where of like you know you really want
to see what happens and you feel kind of
bad and all this other kind of stuff so
I mean if you really like Joe Hill or
Stephen King for that matter I can't
imagine that you wouldn't uh like this
as well and it's like a really short fun
like you know action-packed kind of read
so you know if you have Kindle unlimited
like I said it's free to read on there
and I think if you have an audible
subscription which like I said if you
don't have one yet like click that link
down in the description box and get one
and get a 30-day uh free
trial the so then you can can uh read
and listen to it for free and it only
takes like an hour it only took me like
an hour hour and a half to read it or
whatever so I can't imagine that you
wouldn't really dig it um so yeah I
really actually would recommend it and
like I said um I have checked out the
other five uh stories in the series and
I will probably be kind of maybe
sprinkling some reviews of them in the
upcoming weeks like I said I've already
read the Grady Hendrick one um so I
might be reviewing that one at some
point maybe next week or something like
that but yeah um then that one was
really good too so I haven't read the
other ones yet but we'll see how that
goes like I said this I thought this was
a really cool idea like for Amazon to do
for Halloween and I kind of hope that
they do it every year that would be
really awesome but yeah um so I guess
that's going to wrap it up for this book
review so hopefully you guys enjoyed it
uh we will be back on Monday night and I
think we're going to
cover um somebody had a uh somebody I
think it was Danny had a great idea on
the Friday night Sidetrack show that we
should do the two pilots for a haunting
which is Haunting in Connecticut and
Haunting in Georgia do those because we
just bought those and compare them to
the quote unquote Hollywood versions
like because they made haunting and con
The Haunting and Connecticut from 2009 I
think that was and then haunting and
Connecticut 2 Ghosts of Georgia which
was 2013 I want to say um and both of
those are available I think one of them
is on Netflix and one of them's on
Amazon Prime so we're going to watch
both of those and then kind of do like a
big Mega review like comparing um you
know the two so that's probably what
we're going to be doing on Monday so
hopefully you guys can join us for that
and uh so until then I'll see you guys
next time
bye